hey what's going on folks I've got
another spoiler video for you guys
yesterday when those photos of Sam and
Kelly were released online there was
actually two other photos that I missed
and I didn't see until after I posted
that video so now that I have those
photos I want to discuss those with you
and to be honest with you these two
photos raised some interesting questions
for me but anyways check this out
this is in King's Landing and they're
adding snow to his scene and I know this
is in King's Landing because in the
other photo you can see a different
angle of that same exact Street and in
this one you can actually see the
Lannister banners are hanging plus you
can kind of tell it's King's Landing
because of the stone buildings it looks
very similar to the other scenes that we
have seen here before but I think this
is very interesting
I was already wondering when they would
show snowfall in King's Landing and now
we know we are gonna see snowfall during
season seven so I think by season eight
things are gonna be a lot worse but
seeing this snow in King's Landing
confirmed something for me and that is
one of the visions that Danny had at the
house of the undying if you remember
during season two episode 10 Danny had
her dragon stolen so she went to the
house of the undying to look for them
and when she walked through one of the
doors it showed her walking into the
throne room at the Great Hall in King's
Landing only the throne room looked
completely destroyed with most of the
roof destroyed and the entire room was
covered in something that appeared to be
either snow or ash but after seeing
these set photos and then adding snow to
King's Landing personally I believe this
vision will absolutely come true in the
show now plus Daenerys wasn't the only
one who had this vision either during
season 4 episode 2 bran Hodor Meera and
Jojen were traveling to the three-eyed
Ravens cave
and that's when bran stopped that a
weirwood tree along the way and he had
Hodor take him over to it and that's
when bran the tree and had a series of
visions brain saw the three-eyed Raven
and Winterfell back in season one when
bran was recovering from his injuries he
had a dream that he was shooting his bow
and arrow and during their dream the
three-eyed Raven visited him
and he's seeing that same thing again in
this vision and he also sees Ned's
sharpening his blade then he sees Ned
when he was locked up in King's Landing
then he also sees the weirwood tree that
sits on top of the three-eyed Ravens
cave then he sees that same little girl
from the very first episode of the
series that was turned into a white that
had those piercing blue eyes but then he
also has a vision of the throne room
covered in snow and it is destroyed -
just like in Dana's vision so now that
they are already adding snow to the city
I guarantee we will see this happen at
some point in the series but something
else that I'm wondering is how that roof
actually gets destroyed at the Great
Hall which does allow the snow to fall
all over the ground and on to the Iron
Throne also in that same vision that
bran has he sees a dragon flying over
King's Landing you can actually see the
shadow of the Dragon flapping its wings
on the rooftops of the buildings in the
city so I think there's a very good
chance that the Great Hall gets
destroyed by one of the Dragons
and if annoyed I think it could be done
by Cersei Lannister herself there was
more than likely still stashes of
wildfire into the city and even if there
isn't she could have some more made and
we definitely know Cersei is crazy
enough to do it
she already blew up the set with tons of
people inside so I don't think she would
have a problem with blowing up the Iron
Throne if she felt like she had no other
choice
she would probably rather destroy it
then allow someone else to sit on it
especially if that person is an enemy
but with snow falling in King's Landing
how brutal do you think things are going
to be up north with snow making it this
far south I expect things at Castle
black and Winterfell to be extremely
hoarse I just wonder how in-depth the
show will go to telling us just how
brutal things are getting with the
weather and the people trying to survive
it
remember when old nan was wanting to
tell bran that story and brain said he
only liked the scary ones then old nan
said oh my sweet summer child what do
you know about fear fear is for the
winter when the snow falls a hundred
feet deep fears for the long night when
the Sun hides for years and children are
born in
live and die all in darkness that is the
time for fear my little Lord when the
White Walkers move through the woods
thousands of years ago there came a
night that lasted a generation Kings
froze to death in their castles same as
the Shepherd's in their huts and woman
smothered their babies rather than to
see them starve and wept and felt the
tears freeze on their cheeks in that
darkness the White Walkers came for the
first time they swept through cities and
kingdoms riding their dead horses
hunting with their packs of pale spiders
as big as hounds so now that the White
Walkers are back and they are showing us
that snow is falling this far south do
you think we will see anything like old
man's story personally I hope they have
the time to show us just how brutal the
winter gets for them we have been
hearing about what they're coming for
six seasons now and now that it is here
I want them to show us how bad it really
gets and how desperate people can get
remember during season five episode nine
when Ramsay had his 20 good men attack
Stannis's camp and remember how brutal
they were making Winterfell seemed then
and how desperate Stannis was for a
victory and he told Davos to butcher the
dead horses for their meat
Stannis looks so weak and tired and
hungry I hope with winter here
the show has the time to go into this
some more now this is probably gonna
sound dark and twisted but this is a
fantasy show in a fictional world so
these last two seasons I want them to go
all out and show us the desperation
during the winter months I actually
wanna see people freeze in their homes
and mothers smother their babies I want
to see how hungry people get when all
the crops freeze over I want to see if
some of the characters that we love get
desperate enough to start eating their
pets or their horses with snow in King's
Landing
things that Winterfell make it very dark
and brutal they may not be able to stop
the white Walker attack in the north
especially when they get through the
wall and bring the storm with them we
may just see the White Walkers sweep
through cities and kingdoms riding on
their dead horses just like old nan said
I hope the show is able to show that
brutality
with one hour here and went there
already in King's Landing how do you
guys see things turning out and how dark
would you like things to get comment
below and tell me what you think about
this thanks for listening and I will see
you guys next time bye